well the Syrian army has launched for
ground assaults in the region since
Moscow began its bombing campaign almost
two weeks ago i'm joined here in the
studio now by the american national
security analyst irish aramesh thank you
very much for coming in so is this just
becoming a proxy war between allies of
Moscow and allies Washington it's
definitely a proxy war between allies of
Saudi Arabia and allies of Iran however
you have a clear intervention by the
Russian Federation in Syria you got
su-24 25 and 30 s bombing several
different target packages in various
places mostly supporting President Assad
ground forces taken positions in Hama in
homes and Latakia and in Aleppo the very
fact that they got su 24 and 25 these
are frog foots and Lancers the very fact
that they got these equipment there is
to provide close air support for assets
army and what acid is trying to do now
is to gain as much lost ground to regain
as much lost ground as possible before a
he has to go back to the negotiating
table or be the US starts pressuring
Saudis or the Saudis start handing it
handing in more weapons more
sophisticated weapons to the to the
rebels who are now being sort of crushed
under Russian bombs and Syrian Army
artillery and infantry when you look at
it from a desk all the way over back in
London it does look like Assad is
getting more and more he's advancing
more and more than he has been over the
last few months can he regain control
he's not going to regain control this
war is not going to be won by Isis
forces and without hundreds of thousands
if not if not if not huh not more
Russian or Iranian troops on the ground
Assad does not have the manpower to take
control of Syria if you actually look at
the map they are not even bombing the
north east and the eastern provinces
that Isis controls because they are
leaving that alone what they're trying
to do right now is to take over to
strategic roads to roads that connect
Aleppo to the rest of Syria one goes
from Damascus two humps tehama to sue to
Aleppo the other one comes from the
Western press ort of beach region the
coastal regions of Latakia and goes to
Aleppo why because if you look at the
map you see now that are offensive there
are many of the sort of different
offensives being launched against FSA
and the new storefront in Homs Hama and
live and also in Aleppo so is a side
going to be able to win this war clear
no he's not going to be the clear winner
but he is going to gain the upper hand
his aim is to crush the non Isis
opposition so he can claim to be the
only force fighting Isis on the other
hand he's trying to gain the upper hand
so in case something were to happen at
the negotiating table he could come in
with regain territory and a much much
much bigger bargaining chip do you think
Isis are might be the right word but are
they frightened of Moscow and what
Russia is doing would you think they are
thinking Russia is providing us with a
great diversion here and we can carry on
with our own aims the only air power
here that's actually hit Isis in the
past few months actually last September
when it started as the United States and
the us-led coalition us french jets and
british jets and some Turkish well the
Turks haven't really been involved
against Isis but it's the us-led
coalition that's been dropping bombs on
on Isis the Russians while they claim to
our hitting Isis they're actually really
going after non Isis opposition forces
against President Assad what I see the
map when I look at the map I see Assad
with the help of Hezbollah with the help
of Iranian ground forces that have now
sent about 1500 to 2000 combat forces
and no longer officers and generals
going in there as in an advisory
capacity but these are combat-ready
forces going in there to help Assad's
you know sort of army that lacks
manpower what I see happening is you
will have a clear asset territory and
you will have a clear Isis territory at
that point the world is going to make a
decision and it's going to be bad so at
this point a Putin and us that have the
upper hand they are gaining ground they
are gaining legitimacy we'll have to see
what the West has to offer and whether
the Sunni powers in the region can stand
up to this Russia Iran Iraq Syria
alliance that is now sort of fighting
this war along sectarian and ethnic
lines just very very briefly do you
think there will come a point where the
US and Moscow come together and they
reach an agreement or is this all about
just saving face and neither side will
ever agree the USS precondition has
always been this asset has to go even
when a couple weeks ago John Kerry
Secretary state said well as it has
to go just doesn't have to go now he
sort of backtrack but again the US or
the president said two years ago almost
1500 days ago three years ago that Assad
has to go that demand is not going to be
met asset is not going to leave a set
represents a strong Alawite sect in the
country a lot of Christians are with
them Russians are not going to go with
that for that and Iran the largest
global sort of regional backup I said
it's not going to go with that but
here's what I see happening a lot of
manpads these are shoulder hellfire
missiles given to the rebels through the
Saudis with the CIA helped a lot of FN 6
chinese-made than a sa 16 russian-made
MANPADS are going to bring down some
jets and when those body bags go back to
Moscow Putin's popularity is going to
start to sink ok thank you very much for
its I'm Irish Irish thank you